One, if my cancer metastasizes to my spine, do I need an update on my life frequencies.
So, remember, no, if your cancer metastasizes, it's still cancer.
So, let's say I have a breast cancer.
And now I found out it's metastasized to my thoracic vertebrae.
Oh my gosh, do I need a bone cancer programmed out?
No, you don't.
It's still breast cancer in the bone.
So, if your original primary cancer metastasizes to another organ,
it still sells from that original cancer.
So, if I have prostate cancer and it metastasizes to my liver,
it's not liver cancer now, it's still prostate cancer in my liver.
So, those same frequencies will be helpful.
So, is there ever a reason why I should update my cancer program?
Maybe, but not one that I can really think of.
Well, I do have some people that have a second cancer,
a second primary cancer that they found out.
They had abdominal cancer, colon cancer that they found out.
They had some spots that were lung that were biopsy,
and it was a primary lung cancer.
So, that's not great news.
You got two completely different cancers.
That's a reason to update your frequencies because I have to put 50% of the night
in colon cancer and 50% of the night in lung cancer.
Because that's a total, those are different frequencies.
So, that would be a reason.
But if I have a primary cancer that metastasizes the bone,
it's going to be the same frequencies.
So, it's always good to ask the question.
So, if you have that question on your cheek swab test,
check for, is there any new frequencies?
There have been over the year.
So, I would update your program.
So, I'll let you know if we need to do that.
What you said in your cheek swab test.